das hier weiß Nassa Schund die ist die
letzte Chance einen Platz für sich und
seine Familie zu finden wenigstens ein
selbstgemachtes Zelt ein paar planen als
Schutz vor Sonne und Regen mehr geht
nicht im Wüstensand von Raffa am
südlichen Ende des gaserstreifens wo
sich all die sammeln die nirgendwo sonst
hin
können wir wurden aus Schas vertrieben
wir sind nicht freiwillig gegangen die
haben uns angerufen Flugblätter
abgeworfen sie haben es im Radio gesagt
es waren Befehle der israelischen Armee
die uns aufgefordert haben zu gehen
sonst würden wir
bombardiert auch hier am Rande von Raffa
ist der Krieg nicht weit weg Gefechte
Explosionen gehören zum Alltag die
Geschichte von Gaza sag nasser ist eine
Geschichte von
kriegen wenn ein Kind A oder ne9 Jahre
alt ist dann hat es sie schon vier
Kriege erlebt was löst das psychisch bei
ihm aus wie ist seine Zukunft was
erwartet ein Kind das vier Kriege
überlebt
hat um Hanafi alkot ist langsam am Ende
ihrer Kräfte auch sie hat Wochen der
Flucht hinter sich hat Bombenangriffe
überlebt und versucht jetzt mit dem
wenigen was sie hat für sich und Ihre
Familie zu
sorgen Männer und Kinder weinen Männer
und Frauen wissen nicht wohin sie gehen
sollen wenn sie zur Toilette
müssen wir wissen nicht was wir mit
unserem anfangen soll es wäre besser als
mehtürer zu
sterben das Sterben ist
allgegenwärtig ein Mann der seine tote
Tochter auf dem Arm trägt
Alltag das Krankenhaus von janjunes ist
Anlaufstelle für die die irgendwie auf
Hilfe hoffen und sie doch so oft nicht
bekommen weil es einfach zu viele sind
die diese Hilfe
brauchenam hat seit Tagen vor den Türen
des Krankenhauses aus zusammen mit ihrer
achtköpfigen Familie ihr Haus in
gasastadt ist zerstört ihren verletzten
Fuß hat sich noch kein Arzt anschauen
können es gibt keine Behandlung keine
Nahrung bei Gott drei Tage waren wir
hungrig seit dem Ende der Waffenruhe
kämpft sich das israelische Militär
durch den Süden es ist auch ein Krieg
der
Bilder Israelis und veröffentlichen
Aufnahmen ihrer Soldaten im
Häuserkampf und immer wieder auch das
Angriffe auf die Tunnelsysteme der Hamas
gezieltes Ausschalten von Hamas
Kommandeuren in der improvisierten
zeltstad von Raffa erzählt uns um Hanafi
alkalot von ihrer Begegnung mit dem
israelischen
Militär sie waren in ihren panz in
diesem Moment dachte ich es se das Ende
für mich man und meine Kinder Lob sei
Allah wir kamen sicher durch ich weinte
es war zum ersten Mal dass ich Juden
gesehen
[Musik]
habe die kzen am hanuka Leuchter ein
Licht in dunkler Zeit für jechel jehud
und seine Familie die ist von der Hamas
auf grausamste Weise
auseinandergerissen sein Sohn doev seine
Tochter Arbel und deren Freund Ari sind
noch immer Geiseln in Gaza der Schmerz
ist kaum
auszuhalten es ist eine große Krise eine
unbeschreibliche Sehnsucht ein vermissen
ich besuche keine Familie oder Freunde
mehr weil ich es an Schabbat oder hanuka
ohne meine Kinder gar nicht
aushalte sein Sona saß im kibut mit
Tochter alem im Bunker als die
Terroristen in ihr Leben
einbrachen
ich war sicher dass wir sterben denn es
klang nicht wie ein Kampf es war die
Stille eines
Massakers viele seiner Freunde wurden
ermordet oder wie seine Geschwister
entführt na ist in Traumabehandlung kann
nicht mehr arbeiten wir müssen uns jetzt
um fünf Kinder kümmern meine Tochter und
die vier Kinder von meinem Bruder dolev
darauf konzentriere ich mich es fühlt
sich richtig an ich muss beschützen was
wir noch in Händen
halten und ab je Lebens Wiedersehen jeel
jehut weiß es nicht und doch hegt er
keinen Hass auf die Menschen in Gaza die
gerade im Bombenhagel der Israelis leben
und
sterben auch wenn sie Muslime sind so
sind sie doch Geschöpfe
Gottes es sind Frauen kleine Kinder
Männer und alte Leute die diesen Preis
nicht bezahlen
sollten leider sind auch sie Geiseln in
den Händen der
Hamas vielleicht das dieser Krieg der
alte Gewissheiten aufweichen lässt der
das Leid der Zivilisten in den
Vordergrund stellt auf beiden Seiten in
Rafa fühlen sich immer mehr verraten von
der Hamas die Gaza beherrscht offen will
das vor unserer Kamera niemand sagen zu
groß ist die Angst nur abseits der
Kamera deutliche
Kritik die Kinder der herrschenden sind
glücklich alle sind in Bunkern unter der
Erde sie haben uns verlassen und nicht
nach uns gefragt und jetzt tötet Hunger
uns ganz in der Nähe sind diese Bilder
entstanden zichfach geteilt auf Social
Media bewaffnete hamaskämpfer auf LKW
mit internationaler Hilfe Hilfe die
nicht bei der Bevölkerung
ankommt was wollen wir tun wir wollen
dass irgendjemand uns aus diesem Leben
aus dieser Situation rettet genug
davon auch Nassa sch spricht mit uns
über die Zukunft erst 50 für ihn sagt er
war das aber für seinen Sohn da wünscht
er sich ein anderes Leben studieren soll
er und irgendwie raus aus Gaza denn hier
sagt Nassa wird sich nichts verändern
ich glaube nach dem Krieg werden wir
einen zweiten Krieg haben ein zweites
Leben das nicht weniger tragisch ist als
der aktuelle Krieg und die jetzige
Situation es wird überall von Krisen
bestimmt
werden nicht mal das ist für ihn eine
Hoffnung dass nach diesem Krieg
irgendwas besser
wird